voilà pourquoi il faut faire ce débat
parce que monsieur le pen monte pas
tellement dans son parti politique mais
ces idées se vendent bien et elle se
vante tellement bien qu'elles sont plus
en plus reprises alors là je commence à
avoir la trouille de nouveau parce que
si même le pen est à 12% qu'est ce qu'on
voit en ce moment on voit les copies les
le pen canada dry qui commence à venir
et à faire eux aussi les gros scores sur
les mêmes idées sur les mêmes valeurs
alors évidemment on est un peu plus en
10 manches et on a une carte de visite
qui éventuellement est plus séduisante
en temps on se rassure mais de villiers
je suis allé voir moi aidez moustache
une fausse perruque sais j'ai entendu ma
parole d'honneur je vous assure j'ai
entendu la même chose la même chose je
vois bobby ce qui était un pro européens
fédéralistes fort il est plus pro
européen du tout il ay même se dégonfle
de parler de l'europe en tant que
fédéral vous avez les lois pasqua c'est
l'inspiration direct sur le pen vous
avez actuellement même chevènement qui
commence à parler de la même fait la
même manière j'ai entendu un premier
socialiste à me dire est-ce que c'est
son rôle même si c'est vrai la france
peut pas supporter toute la misère du
monde est ce que c'est un premier
ministre socialiste qui doit dire ça par
conséquent dans un pays où ces idées
commencent à se développer avec une
telle ampleur j'ai de nouveau peur et
j'ai de nouveau père c'est pour ça que
je veux qu'on parle des idées et pas
avec un gant de boxe je veux dire voilà
pourquoi c'est dangereux voilà comment
il faut faire autrement c'est pas
monsieur le pen que je crains c'est ce
qu'ont pris ces idées et qui ont répondu
c'est évidemment la france
[Musique]